before we start the real talk I have
some questions and a story for you first
question is and please raise your hands
if you use docker in your day-to-day
business yes most of you okay
nets are really good it's an
intermediate talk so I hope that most of
you do the next thing is who is using
another technology like rocket or
something for building containers okay
that's not that much okay but you may
know that there is a difference between
docker and a virtual machine who does
not know what that difference is
most of you do I thought so so to not
annoy the people who already know but
still get the information across I will
tell you a little story okay the story
is about mr. process guy and once upon a
time mister process guy lift in the user
land quite happily and did his stuff the
user programmed him to do and he did
this on the machine of his developer or
god as mr. process guy calls the
developer and things were fine things
were good everyone was happy but one day
mr. process guy slipped
maybe it's never there wasn't even
evidence but maybe because God did error
mistake but it was never proven but what
happened is that this process slipped
and died and in such an horrible
horrible way that the whole computer
went down with mr. process guy and the
developer was shocked and thought of an
opportunity or an technology to not let
this happen again
and he said ok when the machine goes
down if I have written better if the
progress process guy makes a mistake
then I just need to put a computer in a
computer so the inner computer crashes
while the Oracle auto
pewter still lives and it was good it
worked was a virtual machine so but a
virtual machine you are having a
computer inside of your computer I will
show this you technically later ok so as
you can see here are three little mr.
process guys why because of course you
need to run more than one program on a
computer stuff like that so the
developer had three processes running
each in its own machine and over time it
was a large family and the host system
at one point said oh wait I don't have
any resources left and again horrible
things happened and the developer again
thought well what can I do to have many
mr. process guys because I like big
families right I want to have a big
family and still have not crashed the
whole computer when one of them is dying
and he invented the Linux namespaces
known to you as docker and he isolated
mr. processor as you can see see here
he's still happy although isolated mr.
process guy likes isolation and this
isolation is what you know as docker
the thing about that is the process
still runs on the hardware of the host
it's not AB some some kind of
abstraction layer between that and you
can have multiple guys you can have a
really large family because you do not
have the overhead of running a computer
on your computer and another computer on
your computer and if some of those
process guys are dying that's no problem
because they die in their isolated space
and in most of the cases or in so few
cases that you can use docker and
production the system is not going to
went down so much for the story another
thing what is the goal of this talk
because I want to set your expectations
right I did this talk at Edina in in
Germany at an unconference and people
were confused I guess you're not that
easily to confuse but still the goal of
this talk is to
teach you what is the technology that
makes stalker live or that that is
behind docker so it's not that I'm
programming a tool with you that you can
take home and use in production because
we will program something later or I
will do that you will watch hopefully
but it's to teach you the underlying
techniques okay it's a teaching talk
it's basically docker under Lu the hood
so we are opening up docker and looking
inside without using docker okay
for those people that don't like stories
this is the thing as a as a show so how
do you call it whatever you see do we
have the infrastructure for both virtual
machine in docker then we have some host
operating system and now comes the first
difference when you run a virtual
machine on the left side you have a
thing called hypervisor that translates
hardware calls and the docker daemon
runs just on the host operating system
as the hypervisor but then the guest OSS
in this case are needed in the virtual
machine so this is the part where I said
you have multiple computers because you
always run a whole operating system in
the case of docker you don't you have
some binaries and libraries included in
each docker thingy here and in each
guest OS and on top of that the
applications you want to run and in the
case of talker its jailed its isolated
ok questions so far no good you can ask
questions at the end as well but if you
didn't follow through until this point
and you have a problem ok oh this was
the question slide sorry now the whole
thing I'm talking about is name spaces
great isn't it yeah name spaces is the
whole thing that that I'm talking about
a namespaces is a technology that it
comes with the Linux kernel so that
means that you have to run some form of
Linux to run
docker for Windows user that means
Microsoft did an effort to create docker
like or docker compatibility but still
they have to mimic these Linux
namespaces and there are a few its mount
the mount namespace isolates the file
access over there I written it down
right to a given directory so the
process again this is this is important
the process itself is limited in what it
can see on the host system so the
process that we are running in a
namespace can only see the files we
allow this process to see same is for
process ID or PID this limits what other
processes can be seen by a process and
we have the network namespace the
network namespace surprise the same for
network interfaces a little bit
different is the inter process
communication who works with pipes in
Linux there are a few of you okay
it's basically it's a it's a technique
that allows two processes to communicate
to the other process that can either
share memory or use pipes and and it's
yeah it's just a technique that we can
limit with that as well then we have the
UNIX time sharing system I like that
name space because the UNIX time sharing
system what could it be
of course it's about the host name I
have no idea why it's named that way
maybe I find out someday but yeah it's
about host names it's they use UTS
namespace and then we have the user ID
that separates the user ID from the
other user IDs and that is the reason
because when you write when you're
running a namespace process and docker
your route in the container because your
process your user ID one you can change
this but by default okay in this talk we
will just focus on these three docker
uses all of them but that would be too
much and we only have like 45 minutes
okay now this was a lot of name dropping
and now we are getting a little bit
closer to the explaining part the plan
to that we will be executing in a moment
is we will create a main program like
really do programming stuff okay then we
will create in this main program we will
create a child process and then we run
this child process in an isolated
environment and that is what docker does
right docker runs a process in isolation
so that means that all the time you're
running a container only one process is
started of course this process can spawn
other program processes in the in the in
its running time but initially only one
process is started to do this we have to
do a little bit of stuff like creating
this namespaces then attaching the
namespace to the child process and then
run it in isolation okay the language I
will be using to do this is who
recognizes this go yeah go it's a Google
my Google made language or language made
by Google that is statically compiled
yadda yadda maybe I will do a go talk at
the unconference yes tomorrow if someone
is interested about go
but the thing why I choose this language
is is because docker itself is written
in go and we can do stuff we couldn't do
with PHP like you will see in a moment
okay
what do we do we have a skeleton program
I will guide you through the program
then make changes to it so that in the
process you can see where this namespace
is come into play you don't have to get
everything if you don't know go it's no
problem
who does no go okay too few
now it's no problem okay what does this
work
awesome yeah because it's I'm
synchronizing to browser views okay
this whole import stuff isn't that
important but what we have here is we
have a function called main and the main
function surprisingly is the function
that is run when you start the program
and when I initially run the program I
want it to be the main program and then
I want to fork a process out of it and
this process will be names based so what
I'm doing here is checking if the first
argument I'm getting is child if it's
not child then I'm running the parent
function because obviously I'm the main
process then what I want to do is I
prepend child to the arguments so and
then start myself again so now I have
child as process for technical reasons I
have to present you the code like this
it's commented out and I will comment it
in and explain it if I do a talk like
this again it will be better sorry for
that okay in the parent function so when
I initially start my process what I do
is I create a command this is basically
like in PHP the exact functionality you
just execute a process it's exact
command and what I'm executing here is
proc self x''k which is just a pointer
to my own executable conveniently and
then what I'm doing is this is a little
bit go through I'm appending actually
I'm pre pending because the order is
important here so I'm pre pending a
string child to the existing arguments
oh s arcs it's like the arc array in PHP
and by starting at the first and not at
the zero indexed parameter I'm omitting
the first because the first parameter as
in PHP is the file name and we don't
need that okay so what I'm getting here
is I creating a new command child and
whatever the user wrote and what I'm
doing then is something that I love go
for I'm wiring up the OS standard in
the command standard in so everything
the command prints out is printed to the
to these or everything that the
underlying command like PS aux or LS
this wants to print out to the OS is
catch by the progress a process then I
have this must seem Li run this is just
I'm running the process and the must
function just makes sure that everything
is in order and then we have the chart
process and that's relatively easy as
well first I'm printing something out
hey I'm running so when this appears in
the lock we are in the chart process
then again I'm creating a command and
this time this command sorry this
command is built from the stuff the user
gave me okay so the trap process here
uses in its exact command line uses the
OS arcs the first one in this case is
the second third because first you want
the file name we don't need that then we
have child we don't need that and then
we have the user input and then from the
third onwards or the fourth onwards here
we just expanding the arguments whatever
they use a road we take it no matter
what and we run it on our machine
because why not
okay so let's do this one one thing when
I execute code I click on this button
but you can't see my mouse because this
is just a mirror of or a second browser
view and I'm clicking in another one
don't be confused okay so I'm doing
maybe an LS and I execute this code and
what happens is as you can see here yeah
basically it's the current directory I
mean a lot of stuff and and the stuff is
obviously from my computer we can do
another thing like PS minus aux for
example
then we execute the code and - uux
something is okay just take some time
and now I have some yeah running
processes and quite a lot as it's
usually the case okay so far for the
skeleton we can run a command by giving
our main process some stuff okay and
it's running background okay now I
talked about namespaces right and
namespaces are the bread and butter of
docker so this newly spawned process
that runs PS aux for example or the LS
has to be named spaced to isolate it
this is the fun part by the way okay so
and the magic takes exactly three lines
if you want to write it beautiful I'll
explain what we have here is another
attachment to our command the command
has an attribute sis proc attribute
somehow my Matt and then we have a
package this is this is a go package
here I'm not sure if you can see my yeah
you can see this this call is just a
package that directly communicates with
the underlying operating system so to
say so and we are having the SIS proles
syscalls is proc petrol and this just
sets attributes on a process I'm about
to run and what we're doing here is the
nice part this if you if you take
anything away from this talk basically
it's that this is how namespaces are
done this is how docker works
I'm just explaining it in a very
difficult way okay so we are setting
clone flex clone flex why is it clone
flex because because we are cloning
ourself more or less and we are setting
clone new UTS this was the hostname
thing you know the funny naming new PID
so that our process will getting a new
PID and can't see other process
and then we have new NS any idea what
new NS may be mm-hmm
what does it restrict okay
of course the file system what else
no the the why I know why that is name
so obscure because it was the first
namespace ever invented and the new sky
said okay how do we call this just set
new NS on a process and we will create a
new namespace for the files and that's
it we will never need another namespace
well they did okay so far so good so now
we have new namespaces and everything
should be fun oh I just messed up yeah
and everything should be fun and the
child there is nothing we have to change
because here we are just creating in our
parent method we're creating a new
process and we ran run this as a child
and this child process gets the new
attributes okay so far oh wait I have to
show you something because this is the
slide before Who am I
just so you know I am N short for
Nicholas this is my Linux user name so
just so you don't get confused what is n
but who am I should result in n on my
computer if it's the same on yours it's
a weird coincidence
okay execute code Oh what happened let's
have a look
panic fork exact proc self exact
opposite and here we are this is the
main thing that makes docker insecure to
set namespaces on a process you have to
be route and if you're not rude you are
not allowed to run container this is why
and the docker installation manual it
says
add yourself to the docker group and be
careful because now your route awesome
not but I have prepared a pseudo Vaz
your version of my program I can
it doesn't change here but here's now go
sudo in the middle and I'm having clear
the lock execute I know your route
awesome isn't it
let's see III expect now to see only my
process who else
I want you your own ok yes - aux and
it's running and after a couple of time
I see all processes on my computer
that's bad but I will come to this in a
moment the next thing would be I will
execute hello I will execute LS - la
execute oh that's my computer so we we
are setting namespaces on the process
but that's not enough because by setting
namespaces you are cloning them so in
most cases in the new namespace you have
the same stuff as in the old namespace
because it's not yet restricted so we
have to restrict stuff ok and yeah we
have to restrict stuff ok
first of all we want to restrict a file
system and actually we do not restrict
it but we give our child process a new
file system and conveniently I
downloaded the docker Debian image
extracted it to a location on my
computer and we will be using the TB and
docker image as our root filesystem
that's why this path I'm revealing here
tada is prefixed with home and documents
talk and so on okay then we defer an
exit function in case you don't know
that defer just means whatever happens
before we exit that function run this
then we say okay must error just means
if there is an error please panic and
then we do a change directory so we are
first we are changed routing into the
new or into the prepared folder that I
have on my computer with all the deviant
stuff in it and then we have to do a
change directory this is just so the
system doesn't get confused because when
I'm running the process in a folder that
is non-existent in the new route or in
the new file space then everything is
bad ok and just for convenience I create
a new environment variable here and I'm
adding bin and user bin to path
otherwise I would have to type slash
user slash bin PS and so on ok so
everything should now be set up file
wise so LS minus Li and we execute the
code and as you can see or maybe you
remember this is something different
than the thing you just saw before and I
can prove it ok something is set as H
and something else and as you may
noticed here is a user 1000 the user ID
1000 and that is because internally now
in the new file system I am my user ID
is not reflected in the pathway D passwd
sorry a little bit of German here and
there ok hmm so so far let's finish that
up by creating our namespaces that are
missing we again have to do that in the
child and what I want to do now is I
want to add the namespace that gives us
our own process list and we do this by
Cisco amount so that means we are
mounting proc to the die to proc with
the file system proc sounds weird but
proc is actually a file type like fat
filesystem type like fat32 or NTFS and
when you are running LS
sorry PS on a linux system all it does
is it reads the proc directory and every
process has an entry there that's it so
we are mounting our file system here
that is the proc file system and we
defer an unmount so my system doesn't
stuck a stick forever with this
container or container had that problem
before I discovered that I should
unmount this the process just persisted
forever was awesome ok so now we're into
a PS PS - aux and execute that code Wow
miss mission achieved so we have
isolation process wise let's have a look
again at the filesystem entry doesn't
work let's isolate it and again when I'm
calling Who am I and execute that code
I'm still root now this behavior I just
showed you is basically the whole thing
that is - docker yeah from that there
are a couple of consequences one of them
being when you're running deliberately
more than one process in a docker
container you're doing something wrong
or you should have a good reason for
doing it for example when you have a web
server in your docker container and
you're running a MySQL server and an SSH
server and an X server because you need
fine C as well then you're building your
own virtual machine in a sense that's
it's about one process and of course
this is like database normalization to
the fifth level nobody does that but you
should try and only have one process per
container because that's the thing
container should isolate one process
there are some use cases where it's
useful to have more than one process the
SSH thingy for example there was a
company that had a lot of
yeah virtual machines formerly and what
they did is they connected to them by
Isis H did some commands and
disconnected and then they moved to
docker so they it was relatively easy to
switch the virtual machines for docker
images or containers because this was
just I don't know a web server or
something I don't remember but the whole
infrastructure or the whole programming
stuff that connected to these containers
now containers was still expecting to
have an SSH connection so it was much
easier to just use the existing
infrastructure and connect via SSH so
that would be about use case in my world
ok last but not least images because
although we are of course not talking
about docker here this is the second
thing that makes docker great the the
thing called images and what you're
doing here as you know I have just put
some files on my filesystem and called
it a day
I can run commands in this isolated
namespace but I can't give it to you
that easily
and what docker does is it has this
layered file system where you create a
file system with a via docker file and
then you can give it to someone else
which is awesome because in the stalker
file is also noted down what process to
run with what parameters for example so
awesome there and the layered file
system again makes it easy because when
you have your docker file who wrote a
docker file already most of you great
who likes her who likes a structured
docker file and makes a run statement
whenever there is something different
like I installed this then new run
statement I installed this who does that
ok and all of the others are trying to
keep everything in one run statement
right who tries to only as have one run
run statement ok and the others don't
know what I'm talking about great ok now
why you should do this is because for
every run statement what
her disease it runs a container with
your current file system does the
changes in your run whatever and creates
a new file system on top of the other so
it's this is the layer thing so when you
do things like run apt-get install
something and in the next run statement
you will delete the VAR apt lists cache
thingy then it would still be persistent
in your docker image because in the
first layer it's there and you can't
change the first layer so this is one
thing and with each run statement you
create a new layer and docker image can
only have 300 layers
max so keep it short so you others can
extend your images but still yeah these
docker images are the in my opinion one
of the most sore one of the biggest
things that are responsible for the
success of docker because it's so easy
to just give someone a docker image
because the technology as we have just
seen is just Linux kernel stuff and
nothing else okay
the complete code is available here
bitly doctor without docker or if you
are a photograph guide and just use this
I'm not sure if I managed to put the
slides up because of the code thingy but
I'll try it's on my Twitter account
that's noted down on the left right now
we have some time for questions actually
we have ten minutes left and in case you
want to ask me something and you're too
shy or don't feel like it I have Twitter
as I already said and I would love if
you could provide feedback for me at
joined in preferably constructive
feedback since this was my first talk
ever so would be great to get some
feedback I did some talks a ton
conferences but never with a paying
audience
okay there's a question yes okay what is
my tech technique to minimize run well
basically what I do is I write my docker
file with multiple run statements and
then I scram everything together in one
when I'm done this may not always be
possible because you may have to run
something do something else and then run
something else in this case you have no
choice but to make two runs but when you
when you have yourself you should always
try to condense it as much as possible
it's not always possible of course
another thing for small docker files
just remembered is doctor has a build
stage in the newer versions where you
have one docker file definition and the
first basically you write from whatever
do your whole build and then you have
another from and can use artifacts from
the previous build so if you have for
example a web application in PHP but you
have to compile SAS or or what's the
other thing less something like that
then you can do this in your build stage
and the resulting image is much smaller
and doesn't have that much run
statements it's a build stage okay any
other questions go on system deep
okay so yeah what what what am i using
to just to repeat your question but am i
using to start the different docker
containers and link them together it
depends when developing on my local
machine I'm using docker compose because
it's convenient in production kubernetes
but that's more like an orchestration
and docker files are again easy to give
to someone else and with the recent
versions you have a very fine control
over what what's happening in your
chakra files so if you don't use docker
compose and you didn't look into it yet
it is you did oh you can do this with so
when you need to start one container
before the other I'm using actually
write scripts and supervisor D can do
this as well as when I'm correct I'm not
sure you know that and you don't know
that he's a colleague of mine
I'm not asking random people okay so
that you can do this with white scripts
so you have already a health check in
the docker compose so you can do just
ping the other container but in case of
MySQL for example if you want to make
sure that MySQL is there you can use a
white script that periodically checks
for the other container and runs when
the other container is up so just look
up docker a white script and you will be
fine yes
yes that's a good question where do I
put this white script there are two
things the entry script and the command
the entry script is basically run when
the container is starting up and the
command is the thing the user can
override by putting something on the end
of docker run that is the default
command that is run so you would put it
in the entry point so that checks for
the other container and then it just
runs the command afterwards excuse me
check itself could be anything it's
basically just a bash script that does
stuff yeah okay yes then thank you
[Applause]